la causa contra Nicolás Cruz entró en
momentos definitorios El joven de 24
años afronta resignado su destino la
pena de muerte o en el mejor de los
casos la cadena perpetua Este martes los
tribunales de Fort laude fueron
escenario de los alegatos finales de
ambas partes
el fiscal Michael sats pidió
expresamente que el acusado sea
sentenciado con el más duro castigo
lo que quería hacer cuál era su plan y
lo que hizo fue asesinar a los niños en
la escuela y a sus tutores
el acusado creó a Sabiendo es un gran
riesgo de muerte para muchas personas
bueno asesinó a 17 e hirió a otras 17 y
Estaba tratando de conseguir más
por el lado de la abogada defensora
solicitó que le Perdonen la vida y sea
recluido para siempre
no les estamos pidiendo que dejen que
Nicolás salga de esta sala del tribunal
Les estamos pidiendo que lo castiguen y
que lo castiguen severamente
Les estamos pidiendo que lo sentencian a
prisión por el resto de su vida donde
esperará a morir
la decisión queda en manos de los 12
miembros del Jurado Que nos deben dar un
fallo unánime para que Nico la cruz
tenga la pena de muerte
Cruz pidió perdón y se declaró culpable
de los 17 homicidios que perpetró en un
tiroteo en la escuela secundaria de
parland en Florida el 14 de febrero de